[Musik]
wie kommen die im schönen tirol
ich bin mit dem kommandanten verabredet
und pünktlich auf die minute ist
herzlich willkommen hier am guten
million zloty zu bei den gebirgsjägern
danke gesagt wer hoch hinaus will ist
hier gerade absolut was sind denn die
vor wildesten und wichtigsten aufgaben
wirklich sicher wir halten nehmen
geländer in besitz verteidigen wir
schützen unsere stärke liegt aber unter
ließen umfeldbedingungen und den ließen
geländer die aufträge zu erfüllen das
heißt was hier hat man einzigen bircks
kommen da stimmt habe daher den der
seele braucht man ja dann ist lange vor
dem aus wie es mit meiner
lebensfähigkeit zu hause sehr gerne der
bezeichnung passt aber du brauchst ein
bisschen ausrüstung hier die ausrüstung
das ist mir auch leid tut mir leid es
ist der rucksack nicht dass gott das ist
auch schön
ich nehme alles drinnen was ich sicher
braucht dann zu danken denn auch ganz
wichtig sagte ohne das geht eben nichts
das habe ihm verschütteten suchgerät
gesagt neben den mittags bedingungen ist
eben die lawine verschüttete ausrüstung
habe ich das möchte ich auf dem berg ich
will es nochmals nobert das wollen wir
nicht nur für die abfahrt ihr
baustrukturen schiffe den aufstieg und
ein ex siegerin wird das zeigen ich
glaube ich sehe sie auch schon existiert
sich darunter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier stecken was mitgebracht
er hat erst beibringen und lienz im
hochgebirge bewegen weil das vorstellen
das länger los wie beim normalen
spaziergehen de ski werden angehoben
seine erwartungen nach vorne gebracht
obwohl wir so weit wie möglich zum
schirm in papiergeld gibt es natürlich
merkt nur gesten für das gegenteil es
geht auch nicht alleine lassen
genau das haben wir im schwierigen
gelände auch interessen die auch immer
ausgeht
[Musik]
hier ist jetzt ja mit den rücken der
abwehr richtung tor rücken heute bei mir
ist
[Musik]
zeil ist frei noch wäre aspect für die
das hauptberuflich machen mit auslösten
und einkommen und weitaus höher
und das als beruf auch bei dieser truppe
gibt's natürlich spezialisten für alle
fälle zum beispiel auch ausgebildete
flugretter
[Musik]
das resultat im vorfeld geleistet von
unserem hotel es ist noch nicht ganz
fertig und bereits im zimmer schließlich
doch wieder geben
und da war dieses jahr fertig diese
hatte im schlafsack
ich habe erzählen uns ab das mit gute
nacht
er brachte frischen zum unter werden
heiß dann geschickt worden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gebirgskamm natürlich im gebirge stadt
den kampf habe ich heute auch allein das
lager ist schon auf 2000 meter höhe
märz immer noch einmal einfach unter
peter weiter darüber wo gerade eine
lawine entsprechung stattfindet was ist
das jetzt eigentlich irgendwie klasse
schüler widersprechen
er sollte seine rechte und die lösen und
in erster linie aus und und war damit
die theorie fertig zum zünden zünden
achter
[Musik]
so sprechen wir erfolgreich durchgeführt
die kollegen bahnhof shin runter warum
es ist können
[Musik]
mit einem soldaten unterhalten der haben
erzählt er hat vor 20 jahren die
entscheidung getroffen
zu dieser truppe zu stoßen und das war
die beste entscheidung seines lebens er
hat hier jeden beruflichen und
persönlichen traum verwirklicht ich
verstehe was er meint das ist wirklich
eine ganz ganz besondere gruppe hier im
schnee bei eiseskälte teilweise unter
widrigsten bedingungen jetzt anstrengen
die rettungseinsätze assistenzeinsätze
zum beispiel beim lawinen dienst des
verteidigung der landesgrenzen und
mitten im nirgendwo wo das schneewetter
hoffentlich weil das sind die die sind
einfach wasser und können und es auch
fertig und ich brauchte auch mindestens
ein jahr die sich das abseilen verdaut
ab deswegen verabschiedete hier den
tiroler bergen
[Musik]